ARMAN HEZARKHANI: Hi, my
name is Arman Hezarkhani.
And this is an introduction
to Google Cloud.
This video is intended
for use by anyone
interested in preparing
for their future careers.
In the next few
minutes, we're going
to discuss what Google
Cloud is and what
some student developers have
been able to create with it.
Ready?
We're going to start
by going back in time.
Let's pretend for
a moment that we're
in the time before
cloud computing,
and we want to start a company
to create a social networking
site.
You'd start by buying a
server, lugging it all the way
home from the store,
and spending hours
preparing it with all the
correct hardware and software
so it can run your
company's web app.
Fast forward a few months,
and things are looking up
for your company's site.
The users are flooding in.
As your organization's
user base grows,
you have to buy and install
more and more servers.
This is called scaling.
Eventually, you're doing so
well that the company opens up
a data center.
Next thing you know,
you're international
and spending billions
of dollars opening data
centers all around the world.
Sounds like a lot
of work, right?
Here's the good news.
You don't have to
do any of that.
Luckily, some companies
have spent years
building some of the world's
most advanced networks
of data centers.
Cloud computing is
when these companies
allow developers to store data
and run code on their computing
infrastructure.
Google is one of
these companies.
Google has data centers
all around the world
that have allowed it to
scale to billions of users.
These data centers house
the computing infrastructure
that powers the Google products
you may be familiar with,
such as Search, Gmail,
and Google Photos.
Google Cloud gives
you the access
to the same technology
and infrastructure
that powers Google.
This means that Google Cloud
has over 100 products and tools
in categories like compute,
storage, and machine learning
and artificial intelligence that
seamlessly integrate together
all a click away.
One category is compute.
These products help you
deploy code to the cloud.
For example, we may use a
compute product like App Engine
to deploy a social
networking site.
Another category is
storage and databases.
These products help us store
data, retrieve, and query data
in the cloud.
For example, we may want to
store data for our dog walking
app, the dogs'
names and locations,
in a Cloud Firestore database.
We also have machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
These products allow us
to leverage Google's AI
technologies for our
own applications.
We can build and
deploy our machine
learning models to AI Platform
or take advantage of one
of the easy-to-use
pre-trained machine learning
APIs like Vision or
Natural Language.
So what is Google Cloud?
In a sentence, Google Cloud
lets developers build and host
applications and websites,
store data, and analyze data,
all on Google's scalable
and reliable computing
infrastructure.
Now, let's see what
some student developers
have done with Google Cloud.
A team of student developers
called Guardian worked together
to help Alzheimer's patients
with a GPS-enabled smartwatch.
The Guardian team leveraged a
lot of the Firebase platform
for their application.
Firebase is Google Cloud's
comprehensive mobile
development platform.
The team used Firebase
authentication
to easily verify App users,
Firebase Cloud Messaging
to send push notifications
to different platforms,
and Cloud Functions for
Firebase to execute back
end code without having
to manage a server.
They also used Cloud Firestore,
a Google Cloud database,
to store and sync user data.
A team of student
developers created
a service called
Nagish to help people
who are deaf or hard of
hearing talk on the phone.
They leveraged Google
Cloud's Text-to-Speech
and Speech-to-Text APIs
to convert back and forth
between voice and text.
And that's it.
Let's review.
We started by talking
about what Google Cloud is,
a platform that lets developers
build and host applications
and websites, store
data, and analyze data,
all on Google's scalable
and reliable computing
infrastructure.
Then we discussed some of
the incredible projects
that student developers were
able to build with these tools
when working to learn skills
for their future careers.
My name is Arman Hezarkhani.
And I can't wait to see what
you build with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]